Hi.
Hi!
When you play something
like The Sims,
the player is actually the
one building the rule set.
I'm giving the player
a toy, and the player
is turning it into a game.
SIM: Wee-- ah!
It's almost magical.
As a designer, you're actually
dealing with two computers.
First, the electronic
one sitting
on the table in front of
you, but more importantly,
the player's imagination,
the players brain.
Being a game designer turned
into a lifelong learning
process where I can go
off in any subject I want
to and it's tax deductible.
I'm going to expose you to a
number of fundamental concepts
about game design.
I want to dive deep
into the psychology
of the player, the mental
modeling that goes on,
how to build
emergence, surprise,
and to try to predict
what's going to motivate
players and pull them in.
You can take almost
anything and make it
a fascinating,
interactive experience.
When you watch
somebody play a game,
most of what they're
doing is failing.
You need to design the
game such that failure is
interesting and understandable,
so that you go back and say,
aha!
Oh, geez.
This is actually kind of fun.
Good.
Games and film have a very
different emotional palette.
Film is totally
based upon empathy.
You can look at characters, when
they're happy, we feel happy.
The kind of emotions that we
can actually get out of games
are very different.
Things like guilt,
or pride, teamwork.
A lot of that is
based upon agency.
As soon as you take that
away from the players,
it's kind of like
being in a movie
theater where all of a
sudden the screen goes black.
Well that's what it's like when
you take the control away
from the player.
The generation
that's creating games
now has so many opportunities.
You're having a
vision for something
that's going to go
out and change people.
So find something
you're passionate about
and start exploring.
I'm Will Wright, and this is
a simulation-- a simulation--
a simulation--
of my MasterClass.